okay
all right here we are in overtime uh
kellyanne if trump runs again will you
help with the campaign
well let's see what he decides i want to
help get rid of biden and harris because
i agree with the vast majority of
americans they're doing a terrible job
on the issues that affect us most yeah
americans americans say
what is the price of gas
here in california six dollars
so i'm gonna i'm absolutely gonna i'm
absolutely gonna support the
republican nominee all right i'm so glad
i have a tesla i don't have to like yeah
uh
okay um corkell with the advent of
social media political protests have
certainly changed since the last century
is this for the better or for worse
it depends on the quality of the
character of the people who participate
technology's just to me
what's your brain today
but certainly i mean you would uh
admit that that allows more people to
hear about something going on i mean you
i mean you could have the version of a
flash mob yes you know i mean you can
get people in an hour to show up
someplace that's true but in the end
it's about quality rather than quantity
right and it's also i mean a lot of
people think they do something when they
just post something exactly like they
got a mass movement all these likes here
and likes that right now it's just a
momentary right situation so you're
saying you gotta actually get in the
street you got to get decent courageous
visionary people who believe in
something bigger than their own ego so
who do you
well
boy are you in the wrong town for that
but i tell you your indictment of
hollywood was awful oh thank you
powerful brother
what do you think of it just think as
big as the culture
[Applause]
canada and california have roughly the
same populations
more californians kill each other with
knives and canadians kill each other
with anything
right well so that's the culture it's
not fair to comparison canadians they're
very polite
canadians got their problems they've got
their problems yes they know but our
dominant myth is the frontier
violence no i mean the guns i mean yes
proliferating domestic violence
violence against gay brothers lesbians
sisters trans violence against black
people violence against women i mean
that's one of the three people we have
to come to terms and i'm richard
talked about thinking it's a great essay
right right before he died violence in
america but slopkins great trilogy
gunfighter nation it's a cultural thing
that's where we had to have
counterfactual i mean
counter hegemonic encounter veiling
forces against that kind of violence
so i i'm and you know thank you for your
compliment but i'm sure the usual
suspects will see that tonight and just
tear it apart but it is
it is exactly what can they what can
they say every week i'm right every week
[Applause]
[Applause]
hypocrisy and that is hypocrisy you
can't you can't have these images in
front of these kids and pretend it
doesn't matter and what's interesting is
that we used to talk about that and then
we just stopped but how is this
different from the watch what you say
stuff that you object to on other issues
what do you mean watch what i say no i
mean well people like telling comedians
like don't tell these jokes about trans
people that's harmful it can encourage
violence that sort of thing i mean it's
this it's the same sort of feedback
effect argument isn't it i mean that you
know if entertainment matters it changes
how people behave right and so either
that's something that's important and
deciding what entertainment
if you're saying a if you're talking
about trans in a way that's hateful
yes
that should be called out but if you're
just talking about it as a subject well
but i mean that's that's sort of that
then you get into definitional questions
people who are objecting find whatever
they're objecting the problem is that
the left has moved the goal post to if
you just bring it up you're a bigot
and that's not no i can't get down with
that but so and also
we're talking about
killing people we're talking about
i mean you're talking about an industry
that does tons of polls and focus groups
to figure out what sells and apparently
what sells is having all this gun
violence and we know who the customers
are and you're absolutely right look you
quantified it tonight if people want to
disagree with you they're going to say
now you sound like a conservative why
would you dare talk about mental health
well there's a reason we talk about
mental health generation z tells
pollsters that they are suffering from
emotional connections mental health lost
learning in fact the american rescue
plan was passed a couple months ago
there's 112 billion dollars in there for
post coven school funding and it's
really meant to be for lost learning new
counselors mental health about 93
percent of is still unspent we can even
shift it over to heart in those and keep
them safer do the mental health stuff
but let's stop pretending it's always
about one thing and it's not saying we
shouldn't make the change the gun laws
also
but that's
part of it and as long as you have this
out there
where everything every movie these kids
see is about somebody picking and video
game you didn't even and video right and
video games
i mean it's a big part of the i think
the school stuff is bad i think you know
it's when you treat schools like a
fortress when you put kids through these
shooter drills that are traumatizing
it's like sending this message i don't
know you should be afraid wherever you
go
you know what i don't want the schools
to feel like fortresses but i'll be
damned we we have armed guards
protecting our money at banks we should
be protecting our children better in our
schools
there's a hundred thousand
public schools in the united states like
the idea that you're going to send armed
guards to every public school in the
united states
someone was saying send the national you
you would like if you put if you put the
national guard's like 400 000 people use
a quarter of the nationals
josh's crucial point about the arts
because any time a civilization or an
empire is reaching its nate deer the
artists play a very important role for
truth-telling because there are in many
ways the vanguard of species in that
sense and when brother bill says well
the comedians ought to have not just the
right but they ought to be able
to
allow for the incongruity the
contradictions the the falling shorts of
anybody no matter who they are what
color sexual orientation i think that
has to be defended but there's a radical
difference and you all tell me what you
think
about
george garland's
and the richard pryors and the moms
maisly they laughed with people too many
of the comedians these days laugh at
people who are you talking about
you're in the legacy of george
you're in the legacy of the great comics
okay well who you're saying because you
are willing to laugh at yourself as you
then laugh at us we've
when i when i see them because they're
just they're not coming to my dave
chappelle not even funny no not the
greatest
i don't know that one that well i don't
keep track of all of them but but david
chappelle is one of the great ones a
great one as well but the thing is is
that it's the precious humanity of the
gays and husbands and trans and black
folk and women and white men and and and
you know chicanos and so forth because
we're all into this human
project together right and if we can't
laugh at each other
then we miss something very deeply but
when we just all we can do is laugh at
each other that's harm's own comedy
right sudden grory laughing at
somebody's misfortune elevating yourself
over somebody else that's not that funny
no that's not true
put yourself as the object of the thing
and that's what you all do at your best
we're just telling that's your best
brother
yeah but i mean
we're not no one's advocating punching
down
but
but but i've seen some comics they just
come and look on the front row and start
talking about how people look in their
clothes and i said where are you going
where where were you at
the [ __ ] laugh factory on a tuesday
night
you know they talked about the open
that's the open micros i mean you know
yeah maybe the open mic
[Laughter]
so
let me ask a final question
trump is going to be running again i'm
sure kellyanne will be the campaign
manager because because he's he's going
to say you're starting one for one
because i had nothing to do with his 1.4
billion dollar 2020 boondoggle right
okay right okay you're one for one uh
and you wouldn't throw them under the
bus tonight so you know
what i would okay let me just ask you
you shouldn't have people on here to
and and make this human dignity question
will you throw them under the bus or not
you we were talking about january 6 and
i wanted to gently remind everybody it's
not a courtroom
it's a hearing and that they didn't have
the guts i think i said balls to
subpoena him and they never do but i
mean you say here you'll support the
republican nominee but like we don't
have a republican nominee yet why why
don't you walk
somebody
we don't even know what she does her
weekend schedule always says the vice
president has nothing on her public
schedule
vice president who's working for the
republic of the country why shouldn't
they nominate ron desantis or glenn
youngkin or some other governor who's
popular in this state
who doesn't have the baggage that donald
trump has and who who who desantis just
beat him in a straw poll so they should
the republican party should nominate who
it wants to nominate but i will tell you
but you're republican
and i'll vote for whom i want i
absolutely will and i'll keep that
private but listen because that's my
right but listen to right here's the
thing they're all running as america
first they're all running on energy
independence uh better cut tax cuts
since you're telling the republicans
they should nominate josh respectfully i
would like to know how this party that
had 25 democrats running for president
last time you had an openly a gay man a
very impressive person you had an
african-american man you had a black
woman in kamala harris you had an
american samoa that's tulsi gabbert not
elizabeth warren you had a female
socialist you had a male socialist and
you ended up with the old
white
guy from washington how did that happen
how is the democratic party this party
black voters in south carolina picked
the guy who could win yeah that's what
happened
[Applause]
for the first time in american history
the most progressive voting bloc of
black people did not vote for the most
progressive candidate who was brother
bernie sanders
right that's very important to keep in
mind right because bernie was much more
tied to the legacy of martin luther king
jr than brother joe biden was oh for
sure but the black leadership
with clyburn and others
tied to the pharmaceutical company so he
can't go for medicare for all no he's
tied to big money like most of these
milktoast politicians they tied the big
money you got bernie out there
laying out his vision and we were
winning in november remember what do you
mean that's the first time you had in
2016 you had the black voters lining up
strongly behind hillary clinton over
bernie and yeah in 2008 you had them
behind obama who was not as far left as
john edwards
uh i think it's a long tradition of
pragmatism
pragmatism or
perception and in some ways how you get
white liberals having moved to the left
was that black lives matter this last
election though brother when we were
winning in the in nevada
in that sense we could have had a major
push for black voters for bernie where
the first time he ran it was an
interesting kind of project they didn't
think that he really had a chance and i
mean i supported obama in 2008 maybe at
four percent of the black folk were not
voting for him but early on they shifted
later
maybe people just are not that in love
with socialism no it's not socialism
well bernie is a socialist he's a new
deal new libya he likes to call himself
somebody calls himself
a lot of people like to call themselves
things but why would you watch this
project why would you want to call
yourself that why would you want to call
yourself a term that doesn't have a
positivity
[Music]
i think he's very proud of that frankly
he just primaried a guy a democratic
congressman in oregon who was backed by
biden and the and this shows the more
socialist candidate we have polling on
this i mean the
white liberal is to the left of the
average democratic black voter no
question right at every time on social
issues and on economics education right
yes most black voters are moderate not
liberal more white men democrats take
the poor people's campaign
with william barber and theo harris
we're going to be sometimes you're just
the black community is very supportive
of william barber and company we have
four people's campaigns okay just says
or even more than the white brothers why
is joe biden losing their support right
now though according to lots of tools
[Applause]
you